[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers John who has
launched a couple books there are
children's books and now he's about to
launch his third and it's had a couple
issues with his publisher where they
haven't been able to sell the first two
books and his warning how can he sell
those two books before launching the
third book so John thanks for the
question I'm researching the process of
creating my own book
so spoiler alert for some of you guys so
it's definitely an interesting process
from the research that I've done I've
seen the publishers typically will give
a lot of support to an author in terms
of helping you edit the book and get it
on a timeline and you can get it into
bookstores but they don't do a lot of
promotion after the fact and a lot of
that relies on the author table to do
that themselves so what a lot of authors
have told me is they'll get you into the
bookstore and maybe do a little launch
party but that's it the rest is on you
dot you go and promote so how you can do
that intelligently the first thing I do
is try to launch a blog tour so find all
the different bloggers who talk about
children's books or children a lot of
the mommy bloggers give them a copy of
the book let them review it and offer to
do an interview or some kind of review
on their blog and trying to line up a
whole series of those you want to try to
get blogs who have a loyal following
people who are active so look for ones
that have a lot of comments on it and
are tightly tied to your community in
this case children and so if you can
line up one of those so try to line up
say one a week for the next year you get
52 bloggers you know talking about uh
promoting your book and maybe doing an
interview it just depends on the style
of the blog that helps get your name out
there a little bit more especially as
they build momentum a lot of people will
read one blog and another blog on
another blog of it spies for similar
interests so if they see you constantly
appearing in all these different blogs
the more they see you the more likely
they're going to you know become
familiar with you and the more like
they're gonna want to buy your book so
if it's a review of your book or if it's
interview with the blogger whatever
format best fits the blogger I try to
get out there and and get seen instead
of this block through yourself the
second thing you do is be a meteor
expert for whatever type
you know message you're sending out
there so it's children's books which is
great
there may be an underlying theme to some
of your books usually in books that
cover you know some kind of theme
whether it's manners or bullying or
whatever it is you know going goodnight
whatever those topics are you could be
seen as almost an expert so when media
are writing about those types of stories
if they need experts to come on
you can go on and talk about it and talk
about your book and why you created this
book and how you hope that it can help
with bullying or you know whatever issue
again you're covering in in your book
itself a great service that I use is
called PR leads and everyday reporters
basically send their list of stories
that they're working on that they're
looking for experts on so every story
people are looking for experts so why
can't you be that expert so anything
related to children if the theme fits
your book you could go on and say you're
the author of this book you have an
interesting story to tell and you know
you might be a potential fit for that
story so something I look at peer leads
isn't free it's $100 a month but I used
to get into New York Times and Forbes
and some pretty big publications and you
know hopefully you'll be able to do it
too for you know anything related to
children and so those are some some
quick tips the last thing I would do is
get a website going I don't know if you
have a website or not you didn't include
it but you know maybe there's a site for
your books I try to get those going
because if people like the book then you
can have a newsletter to then sign
people up so when you have your new book
coming out you know they can hopefully
want to also buy it as well I know there
there are some books that my son likes
to read that we want to have everyone in
the series so whenever the author
publishes a new one and we want to know
what that new book is so we can go out
and get it as well add to the collection
because he loves it so much so if you
had a website where people can sign up
with a newsletter and be notified many
new books coming out that would be
fantastic so you can go on your blog too
or immediate or promoting the first book
and second book and drop hints about the
third book and collect people's email
addresses on your website so then when
you are ready to launch you have a whole
list of people to immediately start
boosting sales and get to a month and
going so I hope that helps if you guys
liked the video I'd love to see you give
it a thumb
it makes me want to do more of these for
you and if you have a question or you
have something else to add to this video
there to help John out I'd love to see
it below if you wanna leave it in the
comments and we'll see you on the next
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]